I hope you heard there was an election
last night and this thing was a freaking
bloodbath for the Democrats a red
wedding if you will it was just a
disaster uh if you're a fan of Democrats
if you're Republican you're feeling
pretty good today uh but there was a lot
of stuff that happened we want to just
kind of do something simple with it just
talk about five things that happened
last night so we've even put together a
nice little uh the limit for you take a
look okay so these are the these are the
big five things that I think happened
last night the Democrats and we even put
them in blue because the Democrats are
blue everybody knows that they lost the
Senate the Republicans now control the
Senate the Republicans elected an
african-american senator in the South
Tim Scott who already was a senator from
South Carolina but he had been appointed
because someone stepping down he was now
elected in the South the black
Republican in the south DC is getting
recreational marijuana which the
Democrats are going to need after this
election Massachusetts got an out LGBT
attorney general by the name of Maura
Healey and the short term consequences
probably aren't that huge because DC is
going to remain ice for the last two
years of Obama's presidency so basically
the Republicans weren't giving him any
bills to work with in the first place
now they can double down on that he may
be forced to do some executive orders
etc etc okay so instead of CNN MSNBC and
Fox just babbling on 24 hours a day
about this let's just do some simple
stuff how do you feel this morning with
me I mean I feel great about the images
that were just showing on that in terms
of color coding the color was really
good right we had this really good but I
feel like the world is just being turned
upside down african-americans or
republican DC is smoking weed there's a
gay person as an attorney general like I
don't know what's next but I can't wait
to see it everything is turned upside
down I'm very disheveled mentally this
morning alright well we'll work with
that dishevelled mentally uh Jacqueline
how do you feel about what happened
I'm frustrated you know it's just the
whole situation kind of just sucks I
mean this is like the worst Congress in
a long time they have like what a ninety
percent disapproval or something but I
had that many you know being reelected
so people obviously aren't trying to
change many things yeah is the fault
here I I think a lot of the fault is
that the Democrats they all ran away
from Obama I've given Obama a ton of
[ __ ] on this show people get angry on
the left at me because I've given Obama
[ __ ] but that they all ran away from him
uh you know they said they would that
woman who wouldn't say whether she voted
for him or not they wouldn't you know
they didn't want to double down on
Obamacare senator don't they think maybe
they should have just stuck with their
guy and that at least would have got the
base going all right we'll come out I
mean Democrats are running away from
themselves in general like there that
nobody wants to have anything to do with
them even Hillary Clinton you know who's
the only real hopeful for 2016 they're
like oh look at Hilary sided with all
the losers you know they're like
pigeonhole they're just completely
ostracizing their own here and and it's
all I don't know if it's all related to
obama but it seems like we just don't
have a chance anymore yeah so as a
person that's down with science I know
you like that science know you you love
that time do you fear that like so on
issues like climate change things like
that stem cell research etc etc that
that to me if I was someone in your
shoes and I'm a science believer myself
so on someone in my shoes I'm in my own
shoes right now that that to me is the
scary part that the Republicans might
try to roll back some of this stuff
social issue is in jeopardy whenever
Republicans are in control you know that
is always my biggest fear but to be
honest like I'm not sure that that much
is actually going to change because in
my opinion both parties are kind of
ruled by business and like you said
Democrats are running away from the
party but it's like that on both sides
because no one really wants to identify
as a party because both of them are just
you know terrible yeah we're the
independence everyone keeps saying oh
the independence that there's this third
group of people that nobody talks about
I don't identify I'm not a Democrat I'm
not a Republican like where is that
group of people I mean
libertarians where the real third party
in this election I feel like and they
were just it always happens or they just
pull our they pull the Democrat vote
really away and I mean I don't think
that that would have made a huge
difference in making the Senate you know
Democrat but but it doesn't help that's
for sure yeah um are we about to see the
worst of the worst because when I think
now how these couple years have been so
gridlock and right I think they've
acting Congress had a seven percent
approval rating sign like that and
Obama's already he was already saying
two weeks ago he's going to start with
executive actions on immigration and
stuff like it forever yeah he's been
delaying immigration he's been delaying
Keystone like he just keeps pushing
things back does that tell you how
[ __ ] up the system is that what he's
saying is I know if I do this stuff
before an election it's gonna hurt my
guys so I'm actually gonna preemptively
tell you what I'm gonna do so that I
don't hurt my people but then I'm gonna
do it anyway so it's at it's like
everybody's at fault all right also he's
being strategic about it because I think
with Keystone for example like he's been
wanting to do that for a long time yeah
but now that the Republicans are in
office he can be like well look the
Republicans made me do it you know so
he's going to be able to get out of that
a little bit but I mean it's like that
on both sides so I'm actually doesn't
t-shirts now that said the Republicans
made me selling goods actually pretty
good at my kids do it too because for a
long time the Republicans have been
wanting to lower social security and now
Obama's probably going to compromise and
do that and then all the Republic's but
all the Republicans are going to be like
oh look at this liberal socialist
Marxist dictator lowering all our social
security when in actuality it's been the
Republicans pushing it all along so it's
just gonna be like a blame war whose you
know who's gonna get blamed for doing a
horrible yeah that's the real war that
we have every day is the blame or what
does it say about Obama that he won two
elections but the two midterms that he
was in office for his party got crushed
I mean really both were district but
does that show that kinda my feelings
like I kind of like him like I would
love to play basketball with them and
have a drink with him at smoke a joint
with him but as far as a president at
this point and now he really is a lame
duck like now it's official lame duck
season but what does that say about him
like people I think like him or like the
eye
d of him more than what actually is
going on I think that's initially what
got him into office not saying he you
know he's very well-spoken and he's an
intelligent guy but he got elected
because he was charismatic and people
were related to him and wanted to kick
it with him like a homey yeah but never
say kick it like you know yeah I knew
you were I was just smelling your room
yeah but now now that we're really into
nitty gritty politics all these years
later we're like oh man I wasn't a
better idea yeah do you feel the same
way that it was more about like the idea
of him in the hope and change guy and
the rainbows and the excitement and then
yeah he made a lot of promises that he
didn't necessarily follow through on so
I mean I don't blame people like we we
just got out of being you know with Bush
for years and people wanted something
great people want to change and he
represented that for a lot of people so
and other thing is Bush didn't do any
good and I didn't want to hang out with
him so at least we have one redeeming
packed with you right that's a bad day
collie sure